Talk briefly about one of the gene steps. This is the gene report that you'll be
getting from me when you look at your report, but there's some new steps that I want to
chat about. One that I haven't chated about before is this BCMO gene right here. This BCMO gene
is under the gut function genes because what it does is it helps break down and utilize vitamin A
or beta carotene in your body. Well, we think vitamin A is so that's really good for our eyes.
It's good for the retina. Yes, it is. But it's all also really good for the epithelial
cell line. That cell line that fetal cell line forms the lining of the gut. That's why it's under
the gut piece here. It also forms the lining of your arteries that forms your endothelial cells.
Vitamin A is very important for endothelial cells. Also, it's important for your skin because
that's the epithelial cell line. So having skin issues. Any artery issues, any heart disease,
arterial sclerosis, or gut issues, this BCMO gene is very important. This person doesn't have a lot
of defects and I wouldn't really support this. But if you have ones and twos throughout this BCMO gene
piece here, combined with this FUT2 gene defects, this person is a disaster for the FUT2 genes.
We've talked about that in other videos. The most important are these top three and bottom three,
and they have twos on all of them. So support for their gut is really, really important for this person.
But vitamin A support for their gut really isn't all that crucial for this individual because they
don't have BCMO defects that really warrants supporting. But if you do have a lot of defects in
this BCMO gene that we do want to support that with helping your body utilize vitamin A. So the
vitamin A that you're getting in food may not be adequate. So that's a little quick about the BCMO gene.
Thank you.